this is the call that started it all
when my mom went into the hospital for a
routine partial hip replacement a new
something was wrong
the neurologist called us my mom is in a
coma and now it's brutally clear I need
a lawyer we have not even begin to
recognize the country's third leading
cause of death medical care gone wrong
the medical profession needs to be
accountable for the errors these are our
costs 421 thousand dollars meds health
insurance taxes all roads lead to the
insurance company their whole plan is to
drag this out as long as they can
your lawyer my crack know I'm a comedy
director this is taken over our lives
problems in health care continue to be
endemic we are not learning from our
mistakes something has to change this
doesn't keep happening to people
you